hello everyone welcome to another
episode of Science and Technology q a
for kids and others and I see all sorts
of questions saved up uh
let's see
let's look at one uh sort of a physics
question from Jimmy here in Quantum
chromodynamics they ask what is color
confinement
all right we're going to dive into some
particle physics
was the field that I first got serious
about studying when I was a kid
um in fact I even worked on uh qcd
Quantum chromodynamics so okay let's
let's talk about what this is about
so
inside atoms their nuclei their
electrons outside the nucleus the
nucleus has made of protons and neutrons
for a while people used to refer to
protons and neutrons as Elementary
particles because it seemed like there
was you know you had a proton you
couldn't split it apart into anything
else
but it was discovered in um uh basically
by the 1960s sometime 1950s 1960s the
protons uh are not they're certainly not
just points they have an extent so a
proton is about 10 to the minus 15
meters that's a thousand trillion a
thousand trillionth of a meter across
they're about 100 000 times smaller than
the the uh the whole the whole atom
um is maybe 100 like a hydrogen atom
which has a proton at the center and
then electron outside the whole atom is
about a hundred thousand times larger
than the proton that's in the middle so
protons are pretty small compared to
complete atoms but most of an atom is
kind of empty space which is why when
Rutherford originally discovered the
atomic nucleus back in what 1910s or so
um he did that by by shooting other
particles uh in at atoms and found that
most of the time the other particles
would just go straight through the
bottom because they were kind of going
through the empty space in the atom but
just occasionally they would hit the
nucleus and then they would be deflected
a long way and that kind of pattern of
doing experiments if you shoot you shoot
something at an object and you see does
it just go straight through because it
just there wasn't anything there or does
it hit some hard piece and bounce and
kind of bounce off in a very different
direction that's a sort of pattern of
doing things that was repeated uh
multiple times
so okay it became clear that protons
were not Point particles so the question
is what are protons made up of and that
wasn't clear but then
uh the most significant thing that
happened this was around
1970 ish early 1970s was people did the
same kind of experiment that had been
done with atoms by Rutherford when he
discovered the atomic nucleus they're
the same kind of experiment on protons
and what they did was they shot
electrons high energy electrons at
protons and they wanted to see would the
electrons just go straight through
um or would the electrons hit something
hard and be bounced in a very different
direction
and what was found was that much of the
time the electrons would just go
straight through but occasionally the
electrons would hit something and bounce
in a very different direction there's a
phenomenon called Deep elastic
scattering and so the idea was that um
that sort of inelastic because it
doesn't just sort of well not quite the
right word really but but that was what
it was called doesn't just sort of
bounce off it uh well okay the the
reason it was called inelastic
scattering had to do with thinking about
whole protons
um hitting each other and sort of
bouncing off as complete protons as
opposed to sort of shattering into
pieces in some sense but in any case the
um the the thing that was discovered was
you shoot high energy electrons at a
proton and by the way one of the things
that was being assumed there is that
while protons are extended objects that
have a definite size electrons were
thought at the time are still thought by
many people not by me though to be sort
of Point particles that don't have any
extent so they're a good sort of probe
of you know what's inside the proton oh
you shoot this this the thing that's
that's basically a pure geometric Point
has and doesn't that extent you shoot it
at the proton you use that as a probe of
what's inside a proton so the big thing
was discovered was that
um there were inside the proton there
was some kind of hard bits that would
occasionally cause the electron to
scatter in a very different direction
those things were initially called
partons uh by my friend dick Feynman
actually
um
and uh the um uh this kind of the the
things that are the parts of a proton
okay so it became clear there was
substructure inside protons wasn't clear
what it was
okay and another part of the whole sort
of world of physics there was this thing
called the Quark model uh meant by
another person I knew quite well Murray
Hill man
um along with uh another person George
zweig who I also have known for many
years
um but any case that that was invented
in
1962 maybe
um
and uh maybe 1960 uh might be off by a
year or two but any case the the idea
okay so let's talk about the cork model
the the question is
um okay first point is there were
protons were discovered as sort of what
were originally thought of as Elementary
particles later on neutrons were
discovered both protons and neutrons are
sort of known uh pieces of an atomic
nucleus
it was a big question of how does the
atomic nucleus how is it stuck together
so to speak because protons or protons
are positively charged particles but the
electric charge plus one in some units
um and if you put together lots of like
charge things that put together like
charge things they repel each other so
inside an atomic nucleus you would think
oh all these all these protons which all
have the same charge they're all going
to just repel each other and the atomic
nucleus is going to fall apart but that
doesn't happen and the reason it doesn't
happen is because of this thing it's
called the strong nuclear force
um that is a well a strong force that
holds protons together but it's a
short-ranged force so as if you uh for
for something like a electric
uh electrical repulsion or attraction
Force if you have two objects that are a
distance R apart then the force goes
like one over r squared it's an inverse
Square law same as this inverse Square
law of gravity
um for electrical kinds of things but
the strong nuclear force pulls off much
more rapidly than that when you get
beyond the distance of well pretty much
around the size of a of a proton and
atomic nucleus they're sort of all
comparable in size if you get much
beyond that distance the strong nuclear
force has fallen off in strength
tremendously
so in the 1930s it was realized sort of
how what was how do you account for the
strong nuclear force what actually is it
well one thing to say is when you think
about electromagnetism electromagnetic
forces force of electrical repulsion or
magnetic uh kinds of phenomena one the
way to think about what's going on there
is you've got this charged particle like
like an electron with an electric charge
and the um
uh what What's the the way that one
thinks about it in in kind of this
theory of for example Quantum
electrodynamics the quantum theory of of
uh electro magnetic processes is that uh
uh there are virtual photons being
exchanged so an electromagnetic
so photons are the particles associated
with electromagnetism
um that you know when you have a a beam
of light or something like that you can
think of it as light waves but you can
also think of it as a stream of photons
a stream of particles of light
and normally when you have just a uh a a
light beam or something where you it
goes a long distance you've just got
photons that are happily moving through
the vacuum or whatever moving through uh
and they're just the photon is just
exists and and uh and keeps going so to
speak but there's another way that
photons can work which is they can be uh
emitted by let's say one electron and
then absorbed by another electron and
that can happen in a very short time the
one one electron emits a photon and then
pretty soon that same photon is absorbed
by another electron
and when
the photon is emitted
if the that it can kind of give a
certain
uh the the it can the photon can carry
momentum so you've got these two
electrons they're just going along
they're not emitting any photons they
just they just go in straight lines but
if those electrons can if the momentum
of one of those electrons is transferred
through a photon to the other electron
that transfer momentum will kind of Kick
the other Photon in a certain direction
and so you can think of the electrical
force of attraction as being through the
exchange of a series of photons between
these these electrons and that that's
and so what's happening is that there's
this sort of exchange of momentum which
is kind of transferring force from one
one electron to the other and causing it
to have let's say a force of attraction
between the electrons or a force of
repulsion between the electrons that
will be the immediate thing for
electrons which are both negatively
charged two electrons both negatively
charged that's sort of a photon emitted
from one and it kicks the other one away
and that's sort of the force of
repulsion and this is happening uh
between two electrons that are nearby
you have all these photons being emitted
and absorbed and that's happening all
the time and that's a way of
understanding what causes Electrical uh
electrical forces
um
well there's one tricky thing here which
is those photons are not the same kinds
of photons quite as the photons that you
would have kind of in a beam of light in
a beam of light Photon starts off it
just keeps going forever in these
photons that are being emitted and
reabsorbed the photon only kind of
exists for a limited time and the way
quantum mechanics works the uncertainty
principle implies that when a photon
exists only for a very short time the
standard sort of properties of a photon
don't need to be there so an ordinary
photon is a zero Mass object it goes at
the speed of light it has zero Mass
Etc when these photons are being emitted
and reabsorbed because they exist only
for a very short time they don't have to
be they don't have to act like zero Mass
things they can act like non-zero Mass
things just for that very short time the
longer the time the closer they have to
be to zero mass and in the in the
language of particle physics it's
that are usually referred to as being
off their Mass shell and the reason it's
called that is because you imagine that
the momentum of uh
um notice maybe more technical but but
um you imagine that momentum is a vector
and that that Vector can be kind of is
is uh the the length of that Vector is
defines a length of the momentum four
Vector which is a combination of energy
and ordinary momentum the the length of
that defines the effective mass of the
object and so that length when you have
these um there's a sort of a shell of of
vectors which are all the same length
and if the thing isn't uh if if it isn't
at that length then it is it doesn't
have the effective mass of the thing is
not its normal Mass
so anyway these so-called virtual
photons these photons which exist only
for a very short time
um those are the things which are the uh
uh what's what's really exchanged when
there's electromagnetic force acting
from one object to another okay so
that's how it works for electromagnetism
so a trap called Hideki yokawa
um back in the 1930s uh had this idea
that maybe strong nuclear forces were
associated with the exchange of another
kind of particle and that particle
became called the Pion and um or earlier
the pi Meson but nowadays the Pion and
Pion is a particle that is well it it is
again it's it's something where a proton
is going along and it can emit a virtual
Pion which is then absorbed by another
proton and that exchange of the virtual
Pion can lead to a force from one proton
to another it happens to be always an
attractive force in the case of pions
and the Pion unlike a a photon is not
zero Mass it has a mass of about
one-tenth the mass of a proton and the
fact that it doesn't have zero Mass
means that when you separate protons
further away it's not obvious this will
be the case but this is just how the
math works out that
um
the uh the kind of force of attraction
between protons is has a piece that is
just like an electromagnetism one over r
squared but has another piece which is
an exponential
um an exponential that's basically a
version of the mass of the Pion
multiplied by the by the uh distance so
it's e to the minus mu R over R is the
typical formula
um and uh the and so the uh a thing with
a tenth the mass of the proton has a
sort of effective uh distance associated
with it that's on the order of uh 10 I
don't know it's it's some it's a well
it's a distance comparable to the size
of a proton comparable to the size of an
atomic nucleus and so what happens is at
these very short distances there's lots
of ions being exchanged but as you pull
the protons further away the pions they
just they they're because of for reasons
that are I mean they're easy to blame
mathematically
um the uh the the number of pions that
kind of uh can be exchanged goes down
very rapidly and so that means that
there isn't a force of attraction
between protons that are far away but if
you make them go close together then
there's this big force of attraction
that comes from an exchange of lots of
these virtual pounds there's virtual
photons being exchanged between protons
that are pushing the protons away
there's virtual pions being exchanged
they're pulling the protons together
um so in any case the the um uh this
Beyond protons there were uh a neutrons
pions were discovered as these things
that are part of the strong nuclear
force now I should explain something the
things get more complicated there aren't
just pions they're a whole collection of
these so-called Meson particles which
are sort of available to be exchanged
between things like protons so for
example there's a thing called the
romezon F Meson whole series a whole zoo
of these kinds of things were discovered
uh mostly in the in the 1960s
um and uh one feature of these things is
and this is again a sort of a tricky
thing of quantum field Theory
um these different particles are
characterized by having a certain Mass
they're also characterized as having a
certain spin roughly that is you can
think of them as little tops that are
spinning around except that for in the
case of an electron you might think it's
a zero size top but yet it still has an
angular momentum it still has uh some
some sense in which it has a a kind of a
rotary uh it's not really a motion but
it's some rotary characteristic so to
speak that's usually called spin we can
talk about quite separately that's a
whole separate discussion what spin
really is we're beginning to really
understand that in our physics project
actually but
um the anyway all particles are
characterized by having a certain spin
so for example uh electrons have spin a
half
um the uh um
uh protons have spinner half
um this is uh uh that's that's a that's
a thing photons have spin one
uh pions have spin zero gravitons the
analog of photons and so on for Gravity
have spin two
and it turns out that these different
spin numbers
say a lot about the general properties
of how particle behaves so for example
particles with half integer spins
so-called fermion particles
um have the have the property that they
obey this thing called the exclusion
principle that says if you try and stuff
lots of these particles in the same
place
um at the same time that won't work you
can't do that
uh if you have particles with integer
spin so-called bosons of which photons
are example ions are examples if you try
and stuff lots of photons in the same
place at the same time they'll happily
hang out together but fermions exclude
each other don't do that another
difference between particles of
different spins is uh when you're
exchanging particles like you can um uh
well that that characteristic of whether
you can just sort of have a particle
going along and just sort of create
another particle that it can exchange
with another one is something where you
usually are exchanging integer spin
particles between well particles of
either integer or half integer spin and
so for example in the case of electrons
you've got these electrons going along
they have half integer spin they're
exchanging spin one photons and it it
works out you can do that you can kind
of have a spinner half particle it emits
to spin one particle it can happily sort
of keep its identity as a spinner half
particle if it was trying to exchange or
spin a half particle in their ethereum
which that is how things work but um if
they would try if it was trying to
exchange just spin a half particle it
couldn't stay as a spinner half particle
itself
okay so another characteristic of these
different particles that are exchanged
spin one particles photons have the
property the smaller particles like
photons have the property that when the
charges of the things uh are the same
then there will be a force of repulsion
when the charges are opposite there'll
be a force of attraction that's true
when a spin one particle is being
exchanged when a spin two particle is
being exchanged it is the case that it's
always an attractive force and it's
because gravitons you can think of
gravitons as being spent two particles
that's why gravity is so far as we can
tell always an attractive Force there's
no anti-gravity there's no there's no
negatively uh negative Mass things at
least well there might be negative Mass
things that's a question about cosmology
that's a separate problem but in in sort
of the normal situation there aren't
negative Mass objects all objects have
positive Mass all objects feel an
attractive force of gravity and you can
interpret that as being associated with
the fact that gravitons are spin two
particles so pions being spin zero the
the uh even spinned particles have this
feature that everything they're always
attractive odd spin particles have the
feature that they lead to repulsion with
like charges and attraction with with
opposite charges
so pions are always produce an
attractive Force because they're spin
zero so they'll always pull protons
together pull protons and neutrons
together neutrons and neutrons together
Etc okay but in the zoo of particles
there is a particle called the romazon
uh that um is a spin one particle and it
produces a force of repulsion between
protons then the F Mazon is a spin two
particle it produces a force of
attraction between protons again there's
a whole zoo of these things and the way
it works is that a Pion
uh has the the range of the uh sort of
force associated with pione exchange is
a certain size because pions have a mass
they have a mass of 135 Mev which is a
proton has a mass of 938 Mev
um the uh uh so it's the the Pion is a
mass about a tenth the mass of the of
the proton
um aromazon has a mass of 770 Mev
um something much closer to the mass of
a proton and because it has a higher
Mass the range of its uh the range over
which it it can sort of exert a force
the range of its of its um uh the range
that it has is smaller and so what you
see then is at sort of a very long
distances protons just don't notice that
they're there when you get within the
range of Pi on Exchange you'll have a
force of attraction between protons when
you get or you push the protons even
closer together you'll get within the
ray range of Romans on Exchange and the
protons will will repel each other again
potentially when you push even harder
you get them even closer you get within
the range of f Mazon exchange and
they'll they'll sort of attract again a
bit more actually people thought in the
early 1980s people wondered whether
there might be a a different state of
matter that you could get to by just
squashing it really really hard and
having it be kind of uh not not the
nucleus not be bound together by by Pion
exchange but have something like fmazon
exchange or something be the thing that
would sort of crush it into a into a
super dense nucleus
um that would be of a different kind
than ordinary nuclei no such thing was
ever found it probably doesn't isn't
possible
um but that was sort of a consequence of
this idea okay well all of this goes to
say that there's a whole Zulu of
particles there's these all these
particles like these mesons which are
associated with many of those are
associated with them nuclear forces
there are also many other kinds of
particles that were discovered this was
as soon as particle accelerators got
turned on in the 1950s people started
discovering new kinds of particles so in
addition to protons and neutrons there
were so-called Hyperion particles
discovered which so-called strange
particles there's they have all kinds of
names the Lambda particle the sigma
particles
um I used to be a big Enthusiast of
these things when I was a kid
um I could probably still remember the
Lambda particle has a mass of 1115 Mev
which is a bit heavier than the proton
Sigma particles I think it's one three
eight five
um so there were there were all these
different kinds of particles most of
these particles you don't normally hear
about because they're unstable they have
lifetimes of order or a billionth of a
second or less a tenth of a billionth of
a second things like this
um so for example a Lambda particle
decays into a proton a Pion or Neutron
and a Pion
um decays in um
I think 10 to the might uh 100 millionth
of a second I think
um it decays that way so you don't you
make a Lambda particle in a particle
accelerator it pretty soon it
self-destructs and turns into uh protons
and pyons by the way pions are also
unstable
um pions Decay most often into
um in about 10 minus eight seconds into
um well actually there are three kinds
of pounds boy particle physics is
complicated there are three kinds of
ions there are uh Pi pluses which have
positive charge Pi minuses which have
negative charge and Pi zeros which have
zero charge and these different kinds of
ions they're all things which are
exchanged inside Atomic nuclei
um but they have if you have one of
these pions they and you make it in a
particle accelerator it has a different
fate so Pi zero decays rather quickly 10
to the minus 16 seconds into uh two
photons almost all the time and the pi
plus and Pi minus declare Decay
um into mostly most often into a muon
and an anti-neutrino
um muons are particles that are very
much like protons except 206 times
heavier and Nuance decay in about 2.2
microseconds into electrons and neutrino
and an anti-neutrino Pion so that when
you have cosmic rays that are uh
um radiation from the Sun that hits the
atmosphere of the earth most of what
survives at sea level is muons and you
get you know there's a muon going
through you oh once let's see it depends
how big you are but
um uh roughly
um a few times a minute a muon will go
through you
um
and you can uh and that so anyway
there's muons are a different kind of
thing they're they're think they're
particles like electrons uh so-called
lepton particles uh the particles that
are subject to electromagnetic forces
but not subject to the strong nuclear
force particles that are subject to the
strong nuclear force usually called
hadrons that's things like protons
neutrons Lambda particles pions all
sorts of other kinds of things there's a
whole zoo of particles could talk about
them I I consider many of these
particles my personal friends so to
speak
um and could tell you in probably great
detail about um about these each of
these things but in any case the around
the proton there are a lot of other sort
of proton-like particles usually called
baryons
and additional proton neutron Lambda
particles Sigma particles there are
things called PSI particles the Cascade
particles because they Decay first to a
hyper on like a signal or Lambda and
then to a proton and then the whole zoo
of these particles discovered uh
and then that was on the the sort of
proton-like particles then there was a
whole zoo of pion-like particles
so-called chaons which are uh the ater
particle just a whole zoo of these
things
um the the mesons tend to have masses
that are at least the the the the the
simplest ones have masses that are uh
maybe half maybe a tenth of the mass of
a proton whereas the baryons the
proton-like particles have masses a bit
more than the mass of a proton
okay so how does this whole zoo of
particles um by the 1960s there were
hundreds of these things and it's like
how does one understand what these are
and so
that led to this idea of the cork model
and it was sort of a a thing a bit
similar to what um uh people like Dalton
and Mendeleev and so on had done in
thinking about chemistry and and
chemical elements and so on uh it was
kind of thing where you could notice
that oh this particle combined with this
particle and did this and this reaction
and so you could start to guess you know
what was the what were the how could you
think about what reactions were possible
and what were not possible
so for example a big thing that was
discovered in the 1950s was a so-called
Associated production of strange
particles
so protons neutrons these are
non-strange particles they're everyday
kinds of particles uh pions also
non-strange particles but there were
these other particles the lambdas the
sigmas these were so-called strange
particles and then on the sort of Pion
side there were things called chaons
which were considered strange particles
and what was discovered was that in a
standard sort of particle accelerator
that was colliding protons together or
whatever else
um you would get uh strange particles
always produced in pairs there would
always be you'd never get a single
strange particle produced do you always
get a K on and a Lambda particle or a
signal or a whatever else
um so that was a an observation and
um that was sort of one clue about how
things worked
well
the thing that kind of got realized in
um around 1960 was that you could think
about these particles as being sort of
you could account for what reactions
could happen and what reactions couldn't
happen by thinking that all these
particles were made of some underlying
more fundamental particles
that uh Mario Gillman called corks
q-u-a-r-k
um and uh so the idea was a proton would
have three quarks okay first point there
are three kinds of quarks at least that
was what was thought at the time uh what
became known they weren't originally
called this but what became known as up
quarks use down corks D's and strange
quarks S's
and so the idea was a proton contained
an up and up and a down a neutron
contained an up or down and a down a
Lambda particle would contain an upper
down and a strange particle
um that's a strange Quark now one of the
things that's tricky is okay if a proton
contains an up and up and a Down
proton has an electric charge of plus
one unit
and a neutron let's say contains an up
or down and a down has an electric
charge of zero
um a uh a Lambda up down strange has an
electric charge of zero a sigma Plus for
example is a um up up strange and it has
an electric charger plus one and so you
can try and figure out from all these
things what does that mean the electric
charges of the quarks are
and so what you could figure out from
that is it means an up Quark has an
electric charger plus two-thirds a down
Quark minus one-third and a strange
quart minus one-third
people at first thought that was
incredibly shocking because what had
been discovered to everybody's great
surprise is that electrons have exactly
minus one unit of electric charge
protons exactly plus one unit of
electric charge and it seemed to be the
case that electric charge was quantized
in units of one electron charge you know
electron would be minus one unit proton
plus one unit Etc but that everything
was an integer number of units of
electron charge and so when this idea of
quarks came up that had non-integer
charges one-third integer charges plus
two-thirds minus one-third and so on
that seemed like a big shocker because
among other things nothing had ever been
observed that didn't have integer charge
uh integer amounts of of electric charge
so that was that was sort of the first
shocker was oh these are non-enter
charges now one of the things that came
up was you could look at all the
possible combinations of up quarks and
down quarks and strange quarks and so on
and you could predict what particles
should exist because the idea would be
every possible combination of quarks
would make a particle and so in
particular strange strange strange
um which because strange quarks have um
um uh that that's a a um uh strange
quarks have charge minus a third so
strange strange strange as a particle
with a total charge of minus one
um and uh it um
it also has a strangeness quantity of
three because it has three strange
quarks in it so that particle was
predicted from the Quark model that that
particle will exist what hadn't been
seen so far
so in 1965-ish I think that particle was
discovered and it was um uh and it was
discovered actually even its mass had
been more or less predicted from uh from
working out each of the quarks roughly
has some some definite mass and so the
mass of a particle made from let's say
three quarks is roughly the sum of the
masses of the quarks it doesn't quite
work out that way and I'll explain why
later
but so the big sort of big excitement
was that um uh the this strange strange
strange particle was discovered it was
named the Omega minus
um and that was kind of a very strong
validation that this idea that particles
were made of quarks was right
uh okay I should explain also the mesons
are also made of quarks like a Pion is
also made of corks but whereas the
baryons the proton-like things are made
of three quarks together the mesons are
made of cork anti-quark pears
so uh for example a um a pi plus is an
up down up anti-down uh pair so it's an
up Cork combined with an anti-down cork
so
anti-particles are always the the
opposite charge version of a particle so
for example for an electron which has
charge minus one has a positron which
has charge plus plus one which is the
anti-particle of the electron and for
example when you if you
if you create you can create from from a
photon actually you can create an
electron positron pair both the electron
and its anti-particle the positron if
you just have two electron repositron
hanging out and they get close to each
other they'll eventually because they're
oppositely electrically charged they'll
attract each other they'll kind of
spiral in and eventually they'll they'll
sort of crash into each other
um and when they when they more or less
they crash into each other they
annihilate and the the mass of the
electrons are converted to energy and
that um and what you get typically when
electron impositron annihilate you get
two photons produced and and that's the
typical thing if you take a particle and
it's anti-particle a proton anti-proton
they can annihilate and what gets left
over is a whole bunch of other particles
so for example proton antiproton uh you
might you could if you did it very very
carefully you might get two photons out
more often you'll get a ton of pions and
things like that out
um
okay so uh these pion-like particles the
mesons walk antiquark pairs the baryons
the proton-like particles quote Quark
combinations
um you might wonder are there other
kinds of particles that are like five
quarks and and you know different
combinations of this and and they've
been slowly people have started to
observe those kinds of things but mostly
it's quote quote Quark or Quark
antiquark are the most common kinds of
particles that that you see
okay so boy all this stuff I it's taking
me much longer to explain this than I
than I thought it might I think it's
because I because I learned about this
stuff when I was a
um a tween or something it all seems
very obvious to me and um uh almost uh
um
uh anyway but but um to continue so so
we're back to talking so we have these
quarks and we've found that you know
protons are made of three quarks pions
are made of cork antiquarks and so on
okay so then I mentioned when people
were actually trying to figure out probe
sort of microscopically what's inside a
proton by shooting electrons at it that
what had been discovered was that most
of the time the electrons just go
straight through but occasionally they
get scattered at a big angle suggesting
that that's sort of a hard bit inside
the electron so a big question for the
early 1970s early to mid 1970s was
there's this Quark model that says oh
proton is made of three quarks and
there's this observation of well there's
hard bits inside a proton and those must
be
um uh and and you know what are those
and they were initially called partons
and there were quarks and there were
part-ons and were quarks and partons the
same thing okay the big sort of
realization of the early 1970s was
quarks and pass tons of the same thing
when we have scattering from a hard bit
inside a proton that hard bit is one of
these quarks
okay
well the the next question is okay well
if you hit that Quark hard enough why
doesn't it come out why don't you manage
to uh just sort of eject the cork from
the proton
so this was a big mystery it was kind of
like and then the question was we know
that uh in a nucleus
um the uh the protons are held together
by the exchange of ions the question is
what holds the quarks together inside a
proton
so that led to this Theory called qcd
quantum chromodynamics
and actually that theory originated
from another observation
um
right so so I mentioned this exclusion
principle that says that two spin a half
particles for example they don't let
like to be in the same place at the same
time
well quarks are spinner half particles
and so in a proton you would have
something like an up and up and a down
and the problem was that people couldn't
understand how could there be two up
quarks there that were sort of in the
same state same time and why didn't they
why didn't they refuse to be in the same
place at the same time
and so what then got realized was well
maybe that's because the two up quarks
aren't really the same really they have
some property that differs between those
up quarks and that property became
called color and the idea was that these
quarks would have sort of three possible
colors
and so when you have an up and up and
down they're not really too identical up
quotes one's a green one and one's a
one's a blue one or something that the
the term color has nothing to do with
the color that we observe from in light
and things like this it's just a a
labeling of uh these different sort of
characteristics of of these of these
quarks so okay so that meant that there
was this other kind of charge different
from electrical charge it was a a color
charge
okay so then the idea was well maybe
just like there's electromagnetism which
is associated with exchange of photons
that are between particles that are
charged with ordinary electric charge
maybe in this with this color charge
there was a sort of similar thing going
on maybe color charge there's another
kind of force associated with that
associated with the exchange of other
kinds of particles and so this other
kind of particle got called gluons and
the idea is that just as electrically
charged things exchange photons color
charge things Exchange gluons
okay so gluons the idea was gluons like
photons are massless particles okay
that's a little bit weird because we
don't observe gluons just like we don't
observe quarks you hit a proton as hard
as you want and so far as we can tell it
never disgorges its corks the quarks
always stay confined inside
and so that was sort of a big mystery
um it's the the mystery of Quark
confinement or sometimes color
confinement why can't you have these
these color particles now I I should
explain that in uh one feature of a of a
proton-like particle because they're
supposed to be three colors of quarks
when you end up with um you'd end up
with a proton which had the three colors
of quarks all different sort of
different colors and so the the overall
proton will be sort of in some sense
white it would be a combination of all
the colors it would no longer have sort
of obvious uh color charge same with a
cork antiquark pair is with the sort of
two combinations if you have three
colors the two combinations are either
the three colors you know each different
red green blue colors or a red and
anti-red those are two ways to get an
overall colorless object sort of explain
why you would see the three quart case
and the cork anti-core case
so okay but then this idea of glue on
Exchange associated with color charge uh
that became the theory of quantum
chromodynamics qcd the theory of quantum
color Dynamics so to speak and here's
the here's the sort of the big
difference between uh what happens with
electromagnetism and what happens with
qcd the the big difference is electrons
are charged particles photons do not
have charge photons have have no
electric charge
um and uh so you know you've that that
means a an electron is going along it
emits a photon the electron keeps the
same charge that it had before
gluons on the other hand have color
charge and so a red a red up walk going
along emits
well something like a an anti-red green
uh gluon gluons have sort of these these
paired color charges and then the and
then the the that red up Quark turns
into a green up quark
so the the gluons that the way their
color charges work is a little different
than the color charges of the quarks
they're like paired color charges that
which basically say if a red Quark
emitted this thing and turned into a
green Quark then that means that the
glue on it emitted is an anti-red green
blue one
um in uh
the way this was originally understood
was using group Theory and um the theory
of the group su3 and the to the whole
lot of story about the representations
of the group su3 and and uh how that
related to quarks and gluons but that's
not really relevant to what we're what
we're talking about here
um the the the thing I just described is
a perfectly adequate description of
what's going on there
so
that means these gluons have color
charge
so that means gluons exchange gluons
with gluons
because they have they can emit gluons
they have a color charge they can emit
gluons they do so gluons exchange gluons
with gluons
okay so what
well uh in the in the terminology of
these things that means this is a
so-called non-abelian theory that word a
billion comes from theory of groups that
um uh it just is basically saying the
things that exchange uh the these the
things that are exchanged are themselves
capable of exchanging things
okay so what
well the big thing that had to be
explained was why why do you not get
free corks why can you not sort of why
can you not pull things apart with the
corks being arbitrarily far away why do
these gluons keep pulling them in and
and do so increasingly strongly as the
quarks are pulled apart
okay so another big thing was discovered
in 1973 is a phenomenon called
asymptotic freedom
and uh
that phenomenon
oh boy this is a little complicated okay
the um I hope you guys have been
following this I'm sorry this got this
Terror particle physics is more
complicated than than I remembered uh
but I think I think it sort of often
takes a whole graduate class to explain
all this stuff so maybe maybe we're
coming out to head here
um the uh
um
let's see the thing that um
uh I was going to explain asymptotic
freedom
so the big question is
when you are
exchanging photons for example between
electrons what's the rate at which
photons are produced
and that's determined by a constant in
theory Electro magnetism it's a constant
called the fine structure constant
usually denoted Alpha and it turns out
it happens to have no units so it's
approximately equal to one over 137. so
that characterizes kind of the rate at
which photons are produced by an
electron and and that determines the
amount of force between
um between electrons produced by
electromagnetism
so we find structure constant is What's
called the coupling constant of quantum
electrodynamics the the thing that
determines the rate of photon production
the the effective force between the
electrons
all right so there is a corresponding
coupling constant for qcd which is the
the thing that determines sort of the
rate of gluon production by a quark the
effective uh kind of um uh strength of
of interaction between between these
quarks
okay here's where things get a bit
tricky
so
around
what what happens is depending on kind
of
how
depending on the amounts of momentum
that is going to be transferred between
particles the effective coupling
constant is different
why on Earth is this true
the reason
is basically this that okay you've got
an electron going along you think of it
as just oh it's an electron it's just
going along it's it's happily doing its
thing but actually it's constantly
emitting photons virtual photons it's
actually more than that it's emitting
virtual photons that turn into virtual
electron positron Pairs and there's a
whole cloud of stuff going on around you
just think of it as an electron but
according to Quantum Mechanics there's
this whole sort of cloud of other stuff
that's happening around the electron and
that cloud of other stuff is around
electrons not such a you know it's it's
a pretty dilute kind of cloud of stuff
but there's always this you know virtual
electron positron pairs virtual photons
a lot of other random stuff going on
around this around this electron
the same is to around a quark but a
quark around a cork there's all these
gluons virtual gluons there's virtual
pork anti-cork pairs all kinds of things
like this
okay that means that around every Quark
for example there's this kind of coating
of other stuff
and one feature of that coding by the
stuff all these virtual gluons that are
being produced these gluons have color
charge and that means that a gluon you
you have a red Quark for example and
it's around it it has this kind of big
coating of other gluons with you know
anti-red green blue anti-red you know
all sorts of different combinations of
colors that are in the kind of the cloud
around this around this quark
okay now the thing is that you you
thought there was a red cork there but
actually there's all these things with
different color charges that are sort of
In This Cloud around it so if you look
at this cloud from a distance what you
mostly just see is all of these things
with all these different color charges
and they're all plus version of a color
charger minus version or color charge
what happens is that the color charge of
that little red Quark in the middle is
screened by the color charges of these
other the sort of random cloud of gluons
around it so that means that a large
distance it will seem like that red
Quark in the middle really doesn't you
can't even tell that it was a red cork
in the middle it's just it's covered by
these things that have um uh that uh um
actually I'm this explanation is is not
going in quite the direction it should
um I'm I'm
um
let me let me give this version of the
explanation for an electron first
um because there's a different there's a
little other thing that happens in the
case of color charge in case of an
electron you have the electron is there
you've got these electron positron pairs
the electron charge minus one positrons
and the electron positron pairs charge
plus one eventually there's a sort of
cloud of electrons and positrons around
the electron which
um in
uh
in some sense will screen the charge of
the electron roughly
ah this is not as simple to explain as I
might like
um the roughly what happens is if you
send in a very high energy particle to
go and sort of uh interact with the
electron it's it's essentially probing
very small distances uh around the
electron and it will uh effectively see
the naked charge of the electron if you
have a a lower energy particle and again
one of the pieces of intuition here is
that according to Quantum Mechanics the
sort of
the the effectives we've talked about
the sizes of particles as sort of the
actual size of the particle but in
quantum mechanics the position of a
particle gets smeared out over a certain
region that's why for example when you
look at light you can think of it either
as photons which are like you know
single particles of light or waves where
there's sort of this whole smearing out
of where the photon is and that smearing
out process the higher the energy the
the shorter the range of that smearing
out so effectively the higher the energy
the more precise a positional probe
something can be so the higher the
energy of a particle the smaller the
effective distance that that particle
can sample and so sort of the intuition
is when you you know when you send in a
high energy particle to probe some other
particle the higher the energy the the
smaller the range the smaller the the
sort of the more powerful the microscope
you have
um and the the the smaller the range
that you're probing so when you have a
high energy particle it's like you're
you're Drilling in to the inside of this
kind of cloud of stuff let's say around
an electron and you're seeing what the
raw electron is like when you have a low
energy particle you're seeing this much
more screened version of things which uh
and and the point then is that the if
the the charge that you see is larger if
you're seeing sort of into the core of
the thing than if you're seeing this
kind of whole cloud of of uh of of
shielding of other virtual particles
around it so that means that that leads
in the in the language of particle
physics that say sometimes called a
running coupling constant where where an
effective coupling constant where
instead of it being that one over 137
it's it's a number that is is um uh
uh for example when you probe right into
the sort of you know further further
further in the 10037 actually gets
bigger and you kind of are seeing
something which is a larger effective
charge larger effective well larger
effective um coupling constant larger
effective
uh it's yeah it's again complicated it's
it's the it's the sort of larger
effective um uh effect of the charge so
to speak okay so the big thing that was
discovered for qcd was that when you
kind of probe in
to uh sort of smaller and smaller
distances you actually see a lower
effective coupling constant
um the thing I was explaining before
um I should have been talking about the
fact that these gluons are just adding
more charge and quite how you can argue
that is not not completely obvious but
but instead of it shielding the charge
it's sort of adding more charge as you
go out in this cloud and so
if you can probe into the center you're
seeing in effect lower charge and that
means that when you uh when you kind of
a uh the the effective
the the effective force between quarks
for example associated with glue on
Exchange
um if you look at it at very short
distances or very high energies
um it's a much lower
uh Force then if you look at a larger
distances and so that phenomenon of
asymptotic Freedom that when you go to
very high energies the effective uh um
force of attraction between quarks is
lower that was an important thing that
was observed experimentally to be the
case and that was kind of a big piece of
evidence for qcd okay so at very short
distances the forces become smaller at
larger sometimes the forces become
larger how does this work it's actually
not too difficult to see intuitively how
it might work
so you exchange you have an electron for
example it's a Charged particle it's
producing photons if you just have that
little electron in the middle you can
think of it as just producing photons
streaming out in all directions
and in fact the the inverse Square law
of attraction is really just because you
produce a certain number of photons
they're going out in all different
directions but the the density of
photons at any given in any given place
that you're sampling goes down like the
area of the shell the area of the of the
of the sphere around the photons of the
sphere is as radius R the the the area
of the surface of the sphere is 4 pi r
squared and that means that the the the
density of photons if you have a certain
number of photons streaming out from the
from the electron in the middle the
density of photons goes down like 1 over
r squared and that's what leads to the
one over r squared Force law for
electromagnetism
Okay so
with photons they don't interact with
each other they don't have charge they
just are separately streaming out in all
directions
with gluons that's not the case gluons
have color charge so these gluons they
they want to be streaming out all
directions but actually they don't get
to do that because the gluons interact
with each other and so instead of
forming this thing like sort of the the
idealized Hedgehog with the things going
out and spines going out in all
directions instead of that the gluons
are pulling on each other and pulling
each other together to make these kind
of um these these whole strings of
gluons where you've kind of you've
you've kind of pulled things together
you pulled all these Lawns together they
don't go out in all directions they just
go out in this kind of like umbilical
cord between let's say one quark and
another quark and so roughly what
happens is the reason that there is a uh
that means that as you pull the quarks
apart instead of the force of attraction
going down because there are fewer
gluons that get from one quote to the
other that isn't the case at all instead
you've got this this tube this tube of
Flux Of of uh uh of color flux basically
that are connecting these two quarks and
the harder you pull the further you pull
the sort of the the um uh the more
tension there is in this tube of color
flux actually what happens is when the
tension in the tube of color flux gets
too high it breaks but what happens when
it breaks well it actually forms mesons
when it breaks because the the two ends
of this this flux tube essentially
become uh they they um uh the the the
sort of one end if you have a cork at
one end it'll end up with um uh it'll
end up making a cork anti-quark pair and
one side of the flux tube will get
another cork the other side will get the
to Quark and that the the sort of pieces
of flux tube will then just end up as
mesons so essentially when you pull it
hard enough it's like break down in in
this uh qcd vacuum more or less
um it's like it's it's um uh you can't
you you you end up eventually just
producing more particle anti-particle
pairs
so anyway people have been trying to
figure out uh is this really the right
pictures it's the whole story is it
really the case that there's no way you
can separate these quarks and ever get
into Infinity without them having these
sort of umbilical cords connecting them
to other things
um you know how does that work
and it's been a long-running story
whether it's possible to actually prove
confinement of corks it's never been
proved they're really good Arguments for
it I actually kind of suspect that some
of the things that have come out in our
physics project will give on a new way
to think about how to prove these things
but it's um what one can do is one can
simulate on a computer
um the instead of taking quarks to be
sort of in any position you can say that
on a lattice and you can kind of
simulate kind of these idealized kind of
lumps of of uh of color energy or
something uh like like sort of
discretized versions of gluons and you
can try to work out
um sort of what the typical possible
configurations are now the way people do
it which I think is kind of crazy but
but that's the way it's been being done
for a long time it's the standard
formalism of quantum field Theory um
you're really just looking at what are
the possible configurations of quarks
and gluons you're not looking at the
time Evolution you're not looking at oh
if you pull these quarks apart this is
what's going to happen you're just
saying that um you're looking at these
are the possible configurations that can
exist at a certain time for technical
reasons there is a a real hack that's
done that treats time is like the
various directions of space
um it's uh uh so kind of euclidean space
time where time which has a lot of weird
features
um but uh that's what's done for
technical reasons when people do
so-called lattice gauge Theory
simulations
and um what has happened is there is
again reasonable evidence that in this
kind of somewhat distorted version of
what qcd is like but on a lattice that
you look at uh certain kinds of um you
just look at certain kinds of
correlations between different uh
between sort of what's happening in the
in the in the color field for example at
different places on this lattice you can
get sort of another kind of piece of
evidence that yes it does seem to be the
case that is you sort of move things
further apart it behaves like this kind
of like this flux tube picture and that
it will show confinement but it's never
been proved that that really is always
the case people have looked for sort of
free quarks and and you know you might
ask the question if you've got a
one-third charge particle and it's kind
of hanging out in in seawater or
something where would it go and you know
it makes these weird atoms that have
non-inter charge and and they have a lot
of weird properties and there are
effectively experiments that have been
done that look for this and haven't
found anything but uh the the
um the the sort of the the general
problem of confinement of quarks has
never really been solved one of the
things that is tricky is when you have
this color charge and so on and you have
this glue on fields and the blue ones
are all going around and so on how
organized are these gluons are they are
they all just streaming out in a nice
sort of Hedgehog you know idealized
Hedgehog pattern or are they making
these complicated swirls like in a
turbulent fluid my strong guess is that
they're making complicated Swirls and
actually some properties of the
statistics of lattice gauge theories
suggest that there is something
analogous to turbulence that's happening
in those kinds of of systems and that
it's possible that in the end the story
of of uh what confinement will be
closely related to stories about
turbulence and fluids and to my one of
my favorite topic of computational
irreducibility and so on but in any case
that's a boy that was a long answer
sorry guys that was a um uh um
it's um
um but I did Cover a pretty good swath
of
um particle physics and and um Quantum
field Theory there uh I could um
um uh as I say that's probably a a uh at
least at the at the qualitative level
that's a decent chunk of um some
graduate class and those and those kinds
of things so maybe I wasn't doing too
badly here but as I say because I
learned all this stuff when I was
quite young it all it all is like oh of
course it has to work that way and I'm
I'm um I'm not sure I've ever explained
this stuff before
um maybe I've talked about some pieces
of this
um okay there's uh just one or two
questions here
um that follow on from um uh
from what I was talking about just so I
I am
and cover those uh
uh Mustafa asked how do we discover the
strong nuclear force I think I more or
less covered that I mean it was it was
really a hypothesis of this person
Hideki yokawa that there will be these
particles that would be the things that
bind protons together and was a little
bit confusing was uh cosmic ray
experiments discovered muons before they
discovered pions and people assumed the
muon must be the Pion must be the thing
that yokawa had suggested would exist
but it didn't have the right properties
but a few years later pions were
discovered and all was well
um
let's see
uh
Zayden asks is there a finite number of
subatomic particles or will we always
find new ones
okay they're not a finite number of
subatomic particles uh the what happens
is
um
okay in a hydrogen atom for example
there are you know there's the proton in
the middle there's electrons in the
hydrogen atom the there are different
possible energy levels of the electron
and the different energy levels of the
electron are when you solve the
equations of quantum mechanics the
Schrodinger equation in this case you
find out that there are different uh
normal modes it's kind of like you have
a string and you can have you can bow
the string and it'll bow out once so you
can bow it so it bows out twice when
you're attaching it to the two ends or
three times or four times and any
integer number of times you can have any
any mode of the string at least in
principle you have a flexible enough
string so in a hydrogen atom same thing
is true there are these different modes
of uh how the electron the the sort of
configuration of the electron in the
equations it works very similar to what
how it works for Strings it turns out
for a hydrogen atom the energies of
those modes that it's by like 1 over N
squared they get closer and closer
together and eventually at 13.6 electron
volts if you put that much energy into a
hydrogen atom the electron will escape
but up to that point you're getting more
and more and more and more and more
energy levels of the electron in the
hydrogen atom but it so happens there's
a limit and eventually the hydrogen is
ionized the electron escapes
okay for quarks and antiquarks for
example same story you get you get these
modes of the Cork and antiquark they can
be in these different excited States and
there are discrete integer collection of
these but unlike in the case of the
hydrogen atom where eventually the
electron escapes the quark and anti-cork
however much energy you put in they'll
never Escape they'll just wobble around
in different ways and so for example the
Pion is the lowest excitation level of a
let's say up out anti-down Quark the
romazon is the next excited state it's
really it's also made from an up and an
anti-down quark and at least the the
positive roamas on is the Rope plus
um the uh
and um but it is an excited state of the
Pion an excited state of the corks and
the Pion the F Mazon is another excited
state and you just keep going and these
excited States roughly the the mass of
the progressive excited States uh
roughly uh well let's see the square of
the masses on a linear limit so it goes
up like the square root roughly of the
of the excitation level so yes you can
keep going forever you can keep going
with more and more and more excited
States why aren't they as exciting as
they might be well the reason is the
higher the excited state the faster it
will Decay so for example as soon as you
get past the first few they're all
decaying and like 10 to the minus 24
seconds a trillion trillionth of a
second which is kind of a short time
um and uh so they're not as you know you
don't that they're that that's why
they're sort of less important in some
sense now but it is the case so these
energy level uh for the uh for the
baryons for the proton-like particles
they're they're more sort of evenly
spaced levels rather than square root
type thing they're evenly spaced levels
um that just you keep on putting in more
energy it's it's like it never ionizes
because the quarks never Escape
um and you just get more and more
excited States more and more different
kinds of particles so for example the
the protons excited status of um uh is
basically the Delta particle and then
you have uh well they just get named by
their masters and they sometimes have
stars you know the the I don't know if
there's a Delta star particle when I
knew about these things I you see I
learned what all these particles were
but I learned that in 1973 or something
and there are a few more particles that
have been discovered in a few different
names that have been given to them but
any case the um the thing that um
uh the question is in the Quark model
you just get these these you know
particles different kinds of particles
that are kind of like evenly spaced uh
different excitation levels there was an
earlier Theory so-called Hagadorn Theory
um which said that maybe the the
particles that would be just more and
more and more different kinds of
particles you increase the energy you
just get a higher and higher density of
states of particles and one feature of
that theory is that if that's the case
there's actually a maximum temperature
that you can uh that you can get for
anything because instead of as you put
more energy into a system normally that
would raise the temperature by having
the the things in the system molecules
or particles or whatever run around more
quickly leading to a higher temperature
but if you have more and more and more
different kinds of particles instead of
going instead of the energy going into
the kinetic energy particles running
around it goes into making new newer and
newer different kinds of particles but
that theory turned out not to be not to
be correct
so yeah so there are an infinite number
of particles but they are sort of of
evenly spaced energy levels and so on
roughly
um
oh NASA is asking how do detectors sense
the presence of these particles okay so
for many of these particles they are
charged particles and uh there are
different kinds of detectors so
um a uh a very common kind of well an
early kind of detector like a geiger
counter works this way when you put a
strong electric field across a gas
then the if you put a strong enough
electric field the gas will break down
it's kind of like that's how a lightning
strike works there's a very big electric
field in the Earth's atmosphere and when
it gets too big for the air so to speak
the air breaks down you get this kind of
bolt of lightning that is a sort of a
ionized the the atoms and the air get
ionized and there's a sort of electrical
conducting path that's formed well when
you have a particle one of these charged
particles one of these uh go through a
sufficiently sort of uh sort of super
uh you know
set up
um a gas where you've got a big electric
field in it if that one particle comes
through the gas is right at the edge of
go of breaking down and when that one
little particle goes through it breaks
down and you get this big sort of bolt
of well microscopic bolts of lightning
so to speak that that's one type of
particle detector there are a whole
variety of other kinds of particle
detectors that work by being sort of
right on the edge of a big effect
happening so another one a so-called
bubble Chambers where you are sort of
making a fluid be almost boiling but it
isn't quite boiling it's it's it's just
ready to boil and as soon as one of
these little particles goes through it
just that just kicks it over the edge
and you get this trail of bubbles that
was how the Omega minus was discovered
actually it was in a bubble chamber
um then there are different kinds of
detectors that the modern form of
detector is actually using uh uh
semiconductors and essentially what
happens is the charged particle when you
have like a memory chip
um the uh it's it's storing that bit in
some number of I don't know 100 000
electrons or something or either there
or not there and when this extra charge
particle goes through it can sort of tip
it over from being a one to a zero or
the other way around and you're more or
less detecting that phenomenon that's a
sort of modern semiconductor detector
that's roughly how particle detectors
work there are a whole variety of
different kinds there uh there's the
early one was a cloud chamber a bubble
chamber
um then the so-called spark Chambers
where you get these Sparks that I like
very much like lightning strikes
um there are
detectors which use a slightly different
effect and um uh than these
semiconductor detectors which I think
have become more common these days
um all right I think we should uh
um
uh wrap up here
so um
uh
thanks very much and um uh that was uh
interesting trying to
um
communicate a whole bunch of particle
physics in a short time but uh thanks
for joining me and see you another time
bye for now